Hi, everyone, I just want to take a quick moment to say
the holidays are approaching.
We all just had a pep talk here for ourselves.
I know everyone's plans and it's a
really difficult world right now.
And I just want to say to everybody,
if you feel (sighs) a lot of feelings,
as we say to children, they are all valid.
And for one hour, we wanna take you through
the show today and acknowledge the world we're in,
but have some joy and optimism
and have a high note for this hour.
So let's go through the show.
I'm really excited. It's gonna be a great show today.
(audience claps)
It's beauty junkie week still,
and we are celebrating all things beauty,
as I always say, both inside and out.
I'm gonna touch on a topic right now
that I'm not exactly comfortable with myself,
but society at large says they are in on this.
Pimple popping.
(gags)
(audience laughs)
It makes me wanna (gags).
Seriously, but there is someone in the VFS
and like, by the way, there's that show Dr. Pimple Popper.
Every time I pass by it I'm like (gags).
But people are fascinated by it and I'm not gonna lie,
I love picking my own, so that doesn't gross me out.
That gives me a lot of sick pleasure.
So, Nicole.
How are you, Nicole?
Hi.
Are you ready?
I'm okay,
I'm having a great day, I'm here, I'm talking to you.
It's my daughters', I have twins, it's their birthday.
It's it's a great day.
Oh, Nicole, happy birthday, mama.
I'm so, how old are they today?
They're 16.
It's a celebration for me too.
When they were born, they were both over seven pounds.
So it's a celebration for me too.
Well. Wow, Nicole, this is a really wonderful day.
It feels really weird to segue into something gross,
like pimple popping on this miraculous day
when you've created two 16 year olds in your belly.
Oh, I'm so happy for you. I have eight and six.
I feel like I'll never get to 16.
So thank you for sharing that Everest.
And we wish you the very best today.
Okay. Pro pimple popping.
Give it to me real quick.
Thank you.
(Drew gags)
I can't even tell you. I don't know how this started for me.
I am fascinated with watching this.
I guess, growing up, you get pimples, you pop them.
I don't know, but Facebook decided
that I might want to watch clips of this
and it came up in the feed and of course, just like you,
I was like, oh my gosh, this is so disgusting.
But at the same time, I couldn't stop watching it.
And so I don't know, it keeps coming up in my feed
and I just I'm fascinated by it.
Wow. Facebook really has a way don't they? I love it.
Well, thank you for sharing that, Nicole.
And I don't think you're alone.
Anyone in the wall, raise your hand if you're
sickly attracted or addicted to looking at it.
Anyone?
Yeah. I'm with you, ma'am who's shaking her head.
But even on yourself? No.
Okay. No, just no pimple popping period.
(upbeat music)